hey come see us for our fall tour dates
we're gonna be in Houston Texas on
September 4th and then the dates after
that we're gonna be in New Orleans
Norman's I was kind of ambivalent how I
wanted to yeah you didn't make it you
know awful incision you got to make a
decision
Birmingham Alabama Jacksonville Florida
Tampa Florida Albuquerque New Mexico
Phoenix Arizona Sacramento California
and down in Valley Center California
rounded out at November 23rd go to rhett
and Link live.com to check out our stuff
now let's do a biscuit welcome to ear
biscuits I'm Rhett and I'm Linc this
week at the round table of dim lighting
we're asking the question do we consider
Los Angeles home what what what makes a
house a home
what makes a state or a city or a new
place that you didn't always call home a
home and do we do that
with Los Angeles at this point hmm and I
do want to just go ahead and apologize
this week I'm gonna be the guy who
apologizes for being sick I don't even
know if my voice sounds different
I can't ice to me I sound like I'm
inside of like a barrel well first of
all let me say that if this is just you
saying that you're gonna be apologizing
for all sorts of things over this
episode then I'm all for that no I'm
only apologizing for if the sound of Jay
being sick see now you're saying you're
not gonna apologize for anything else if
I do if I do something that's apology
worthy I will apologize good but
secondly you sound like yeah you do
sound like you're in a barrel I only in
my own ears I feel like listening to
myself now that I'm not completely out
of the barrel because I'm not completely
over the thing that apparently I
transferred to you I don't believe that
you gave it to me yeah well how did it
start
sore throat yeah but as we discussed on
the previous air biscuit all of my cold
to start with a sore throat what is it
right now it's it's uh it's moved to
just stuffiness and ache
I would have a headache if I were
heightened taking ibuprofen yeah okay
all right but what I'm saying is that
it's not like I want to take credit you
haven't been contagious for you had not
been contagious for what I would
consider like at least a week before I
got mutton before my symptoms showed up
I mean I get I don't know how colds work
I've had this for three weeks
maybe but you've had a residual sinus
infection which I don't think I can
catch a sinus infection I can catch the
initial viral cold situation which maybe
you maybe was on something maybe you put
it on something and for some reason it
lived and then I ended up licking
something by accident well I have been
randomly licking objects in your in the
office well I I told Christy that you
weren't coming in this you were just
coming in for this this afternoon not
this morning because I apparently gave
you a cold she was like wait I'm not
sick he didn't give it to me
and we sleep together and I didn't give
it to my wife and we sleep together and
my kids who but most like especially my
I mean if we're gonna if you're gonna
get something you're probably gonna get
it from me cuz I mean this the stuff we
end up well we're trapped
yeah we're yelling at each other right
now I think we're trapped in the same
articles yeah being fired at your
orifices right now out of my orifices
we're trapped in the same room am I more
[ __ ] now because I obviously I share a
bed and a in a bedroom with my wife but
I have like a I got a special air
purifier in there it's like constantly
catching things we've got a weird one
that like we won for like that our wives
we got from Ellen remember that yeah we
have a weird one from Ellen in our
office Kristi and Jesse went to a taping
of Ellen and it was one of those days
they she gave everyone in the audience
some weird air purifier and we've got it
and it's always on but I do not believe
that it works it's never been it filters
never been changed but Jesse always
faces away from you when sleeping
because there's a distance between the
two of you no actually you know what
this is interesting because you know
this because you and Kristi shared a
very very small like single bed double
it was a double bed but a double bed to
me a person
my size that's a single bet that's a
twin bed if I get into a double bed with
someone I am making full contact with
them my leg
also cuz I sleep on my side so I take up
a lot of lateral space I do not like to
be I'm such a light sleeper I do not
like to be touched while sleeping
because I will wake up and so but jesse
is a deep sleeper and she's also you
know like a super cuddle monster and so
so she is kind usually we wake up and
I'm on the edge of my bed and she's in
my spot like she has moved me all the
way to the side that's usually how we
wake up but also she is she's like you
know and I think you've done this you've
accidentally struck your wife that's
while sleeping by like getting moving
around it on a weekly basis I wake
myself up realizing that in flailing my
right arm I've either struck her or
almost struck ER and the thing is is
that I am probably if there is a
spectrum of like accident avoidance like
how much accident avoidance do you have
and I don't know if it's just something
about being really big and feeling like
I've got I take up a lot of space I
believe that I am on the complete upper
end almost off the spectrum of accident
avoidance like I hate to accidentally
bump my head into things you sleep like
you're mummified I don't step on
people's feet like a lot of tall people
just step on people my wife will step on
your foot if you if you spend more than
four hours with her she will step on you
this is what she does and I think it's
cuz she's just little and short and so
she feels like she can't do any harm and
so it transfers to the bedroom and she's
never really clocked me in the face but
I have this phobia of her elbowing me
are punching me in the nose and so
subconsciously I sleep on my side facing
away from her
you're like flinching but now that I've
got this cold and I have a deviated
septum I've given you all kinds of
information take it and do what you will
with it my left nostril is much
more has a lot more airflow than my
right nostril when I get sick my right
nostril is almost useless so but in
order to lay on my if I when you know I
when you lay on one side and then the
drainage goes down and one of the
nostrils opens up when you're sick yeah
that's facing her because I sleep on the
right side of the bed so now I am
completely in it and while I'm sick I'm
sleeping on my right side completely
exposed I've been thinking about wearing
like a hockey mask but I think that the
hockey mask would work against like the
airflow so I'm really I really don't
know what to do basically maybe a
catcher's mask a catcher's mask lets a
lot of air yeah like a lacrosse helmet
or that yeah something like that a
football helmet would allow but quite a
bit of breeze as well like a kickers
helmet that just has just has like
old-school kickers wears just one they
don't do that anymore if I was a kicker
I got a full thing now if I was a kicker
I'd have the one thing butt kickers
tackle now kickers got a tackle got to
do it all it's very competitive this the
world's a competitive place now because
I don't know because of the internet
because of the internet well I it I mean
I Scott I had to resort to the neti pot
I was like I'm going back to this thing
but hey done it before I many years ago
and then there was the thing we're sigh
oh don't use a neti pot because you'll
get like a brain-eating ameba from the
tap and now when you when you buy one
it's got this big warning on it says use
distilled distilled water I don't use
distilled water use tap yeah because
it's just a hassle I mean prized of all
people that you're using tap won it from
one nostril boy and that feels I was
weird I like I did it right before I
came so so if I start going cross-eyed
you know I got the amoeba just be ready
for it
the reason I so I do have distilled
water and I something does something
come out when you did it yeah just a
little snot no not not a lot of stuff I
love it I mean I had the full-blown
sinus infection I had colors coming out
of mine
that I don't know you could paint a
mural with it you got brown stuff coming
up I mean there was bright red action oh
well that's me it was huh that's blood
yeah I was bleeding and then there was
hmm I don't want to talk about this
anymore it was like sometimes I put more
spinach in my breakfast smoothie and it
goes a little greener and it's is you
need it's typically brown I don't think
I don't think spinach you know I think
chloroform or whatever it is that makes
a little a little green actually makes
its way into your snot but I use the tap
water because those instances of the
people getting the brain-eating ameba is
like it's so unlikely that's all a jug
of distilled water no you and you know
it you should use it it is your is my
homie it also depends on your water
supply we left the same water supply no
no I but I don't think that I I think
that most of those instances have I
don't think any of them have been in
Southern California also I have a
filtration system built into my house
hurry up listen that him and I have a UV
light that would listen to hear I have a
UV bulb this is the previous homeowner
they installed all this and I just and
I'm just maintenance got central vacuum
yes but we took that out don't need that
it was very old and non functioning yeah
the guy who the family who had this
house before was all they were all about
the central vac the yeah well it gets
dated but listen about that neti pot if
you've never used one let me tell you
you throw it you throw that thing on one
nostril and then you start leaning to
the side and first of all if you try to
follow the instructions on the back of
the thing it like says weird stuff like
rotate to your chin but don't move your
chin out beyond the neti pot it's like
doesn't makes its office intuitive just
do it until it feels right do it until
it feels right but if it feels wrong it
can feel very wrong and even when it
feels right it feels wrong because
you're filling up that nut until you get
my recommendation is to watch a youtube
video but but truck I mean what's the
worst that can happen
beside the brain-eating ameba the first
time you do it water going down your
throat you feel like you're you feel
like you might be drowning yourself the
first time you do it
once you adjust and get the angles right
cuz I because I made my I made Locke do
it
Shepard wouldn't do it made him do it
and I'm just grabbed him by a head full
of hair and just like some of the neti
pot in his nostril they just did he just
tilted his head I was like dude you
gotta get where you gotta get word you
can be in control of this innit it's
weird it's a weird feeling it's not that
the feeling goes away it's just that you
learn to expect it but I mean the first
time you do it and it had been many
years so it was very fresh to me it was
like I felt like I was filling up my
whole brain cavity with salt water
because he mixing that salt water
solution yeah nothing's coming out the
other side so I'm like and it's just
half the pots going up my nose nothing
coming out and I'm like where is this
guy's it'll blow out my ear you're
blocked and I started hearing a weird
thing in my ear and it just it started
to burn a little bit but it felt like
it's all connected felt like my eyes
will go like float out in it and it's
just yeah you felt like you're drowning
yourself that's one nostril because all
that happens to me when I'm super
stuffed is it just I I can feel it
trying to go into the other side and
then just going down the back of my
throat and become about my mouth so it's
like pushing up against all the stuff
that's in there but it can't get through
but if a glop comes out that feels that
that's satisfying that's what you want I
think I became dependent on it last time
I got sick there there are people who I
was doing it morning middle of the day
and night they got a new one that's
powered have you seen the commercial for
the one that you don't even bend you
don't bend sideways you just put you put
it on your face and it powers the water
in one side and just out the other side
not necessary it literally takes it out
and puts it into like a reservoir so you
just like it's like putting on a mask
why you can drink it later
we could save it and you could see the
blood you can see all the nasty things
and know exactly what happens that of
having a look in the sink it's a weird
feeling are we talking about getting
your whole head filled up with saline
solution anyway I feel like I still got
to shake it out I hope I don't have I
hope what happened to you doesn't happen
to me
I am I don't think you could take it I
am doing the neti pot ahead of time
so that I don't wait until I get the
sinus infection to do the neti pot
however some people say that the neti
pot actually contributes to sinus
infections because it gets rid of the
mucus and the mucus is what's doing the
job
just don't mess with it let it don't try
to treat it just let it I don't but it
just makes me feel good okay and just
and living on the edge living right on
the edge of a brainy eating amoeba it
makes me feel alive every time I wake up
the next day after doing a doing the
neti pot I'm like another day I made it
you sound like an anti-vaxxer another
day I made it I know I'm not right about
this I'm glad I made it another day I
can't seem right about it shout out to
all the anti-vaxxers listening well
you're out there we know you're out
there
way out there Jessica Biel's a big fan
okay so we're gonna answer we're gonna
answer some questions that you asked us
but first we're gonna let you know that
you can get a number of grooming
products we've got lip balms we each
have one I'm gonna hold up both of ours
linked peculiarly perfect peanut butter
peppermint lip balm and rats wooden
berries wonderfully wild you can get
these and all types of packs mythical
dot store put them on your lips and
think about us you can also put my beard
oil on your beard and think about me
or link you can put the mythical pomade
into your hair which is what we do every
day you can also spray what link has in
his hands on your body
mythical number nine this is some good
smelling stuff I'm very proud of the way
that this smells you know what it should
say on the back smell that it's you know
well it smell it at it does it has we
try to do like a perfectly balanced
unison love it on a woman I love it on
me yeah I love it on I love it on anima
I've never put it on an animal no in
fact has never been put on animal so
never touch items
don't you make your wife wear that when
she wears perfume she likes it
no no no no but what I'm saying is that
your wife doesn't wear traditional
perfumes because it gives you a headache
but this is this is a I think it's it's
a traditional cologne perfume it doesn't
give you a headache so if the majority
of perfumes and colognes give me a
headache there you go this doesn't know
I don't know why it works but it doesn't
give links link headache so maybe it
will give you headaches mythical dot
store don't get headaches let's start
with a question that so will do the home
question second yeah we're gonna start
with a question that actually comes from
my wife oh really yeah
my wife has a rather vibrant Twitter
account really lost Fame jealous a
little cash out on you know speaking of
seeing Los Angeles as home she decided
to call her you get it lost fabulously
you get it you get it yeah fam but she
did she didn't respond to us by asking a
question this is just something she
tweeted you're commandeering for our
conversation which is fine but I don't
want to insinuate that she's shamelessly
responding to our props she did ask me
this question as well though I mean so
like technically I feel I feel fine
about commandeering it you may have seen
a while back it was already a couple
weeks when we were recording this but
Barbra Streisand she's got a dog she had
a dog named Samantha that was like a
poodle kind of looks like Barbara but
hairier meaning Barbara your dog yeah
not kind of looks like Barbara yeah not
and incidentally Barbara isn't my dog is
not named after Barbra Streisand she's
named after Barbara Mandrell but Barbra
Streisand has cloned her dog at least
three times because three of them are
currently alive and she posted this
picture you may have seen it where she
took the three clone dogs to the grave
site of the original dog and they were
in the family photo did
a photo she put the three dogs on top of
the grave okay and as you might guess
they all look the same and then there's
a picture of the original dog the
identical yeah the original dog has a
picture like a color picture of itself
on the grave so you've got basically
four identical dogs in the picture which
cost more a full color rendering
gravestone of a dog or a cloned dog I
think a clone dog
considering that she claims to have paid
fifty thousand dollars for it to have
been done or left are the news claims
that that's what it was and just a few
years ago it was a hundred thousand
dollars to get it done that it's getting
cheaper prices coming down that's good
and so I bye bye Jesse now have
seriously discussed the question before
and I'm really surprised that as
attached as you are to Jade and how
perfect do you think that she is why you
haven't talked about this now I'm not
gonna put her question is happy Sunday
is cloning your dog sweet or creepy she
made a poll she made a poll over 1,100
people responded to my wife's poll the
two options were the sweetest with some
dog and hard him was the last time she
responded to your poll well not well I'm
sick at least and then the other option
was that mess is creepy 76 percent of
people as you might guess said that mess
is creepy 24 percent said the sweetest
well I mean once you set up the whole
Barbra Streisand does a photo shoot at
the graveyard with three dogs dancing on
their you know their forefather or four
mother that obviously seems creepy well
yeah but so let's it's a naturalist
detach from that let's forget that we
know about that and let's try to analyze
this question fresh now the 199th
episode so a couple back I mean we did
we had a truncated conversation about
our dogs and what we would do if they
died the so thank you for for your
feedback being part of that conversation
hashtag your biscuit but we didn't we
didn't talk about at least in my
recollect
we didn't talk about cloning of dogs as
an option not in that I think we may
have thought about it at some point but
not in that episode gives me pause I
mean I think about it because it's like
Jade I wonder if the personality would
be exactly the same I mean it it's
genetics plus environment the
environment would be exactly the same so
I guess so I mean I'm sure there are so
there's mutations that take place any
time there's a clone I might do it just
to find out that just to see if if it's
let's just assume that the price is
reasonable I'm not gonna pay fifty
thousand dollars to have this done but
by the time Barbara is in the market for
cloning maybe it'll be twenty five maybe
it'll be ten and would you pay ten
thousand dollars to save Jade's life
like if there was a life's life altering
a lot of people will pay thousands of
dollars if their dog gets in trouble now
we adopted our dog so we didn't pay
anything for them well actually they do
still charge you well they say they
charge an adoption fee donation fee
stuff going but I mean a couple hundred
bucks whatever but if you had to like
okay Jade has this life-threatening
condition you have to get surgery yeah I
assume that you pay thousands of dollars
for that surgery to be done I'd do that
for Barbara I mean I I'm in a position
financially where I can afford to do it
it's not an irresponsible decision that
helps me make that that makes the
decision easier if you're all of a
sudden gonna like be choosing between
feeding your children or saving your dog
at that point okay it's a different
story I mean another factor is if I mean
if we're talking about the surgery like
what are the chances of success versus
the quality of life afterward because
like we talked about before and how old
is Jade at the time versus her life
according to okay oh man I mean I kind
of like I mean if I was liking the
overlap idea which I've since pull back
from but now I'm going back in with
overlapping with an identical but that's
I would not pay ten grand that is Street
plus fifty right now I wouldn't pay ten
okay I mean all right let's take
finances off of the table
is it creepier it's free you can do it
for free of course it's creepy because
cloning is creepy and if we don't have a
slightly creeped out response to cloning
then we're probably not in touch with
ourselves it's weird right it's weird to
be able to clone something and or
someone it's not natural but the process
is not that unlike twins you know
genetically which twins are creepy on
their own I do admit that definitely but
I think I would do it the main reason I
wouldn't do it the main reason I would
not clone Barbara is because of the
judgment that I would receive and I just
would feel like I'd have to defend
myself and I don't really have a defense
other than I just really like Barbara
yeah I don't think I don't know what I'm
gonna get next time I get a dog I think
it should be secret but if it got out it
should be unjust but there is also the
sort of the lottery of who is Jade
living so long well she's she's 75 she's
amazing I've been telling you but I do
like the idea first of all okay I see a
puppy again maybe here's a reason not to
clone the dog from from an ethical
standpoint because dogs need to be
adopted right so by cloning a dog you're
bringing another dog into the world as
opposed to adopting another dog so I
could adopt another dog that needs a
home next time just like we did with
Barbara yeah it is a and I think so
that's so there's a reason to not do it
there's something to pair with that
which is it is a relationship I mean our
dogs are family members they're dog
family members but they are family
members and it's so it's a relationship
that then with a newt you just don't
want to have you don't want to fabricate
just for your own convenience a
relationship with the with a clone it
just seems like you're just trying to
care perpetuate something that and deny
something that is a part of life which
is death and an opportunity to forge a
new relationship with all of its
challenges and joys I mean it's yeah
what did the new dogs of figuratively
then yeah that yeah that's that's the
risk you know like we got somebody
working on our house right now the
contractor who of course Barbara loves
because he is a person and the way he
described her the other day
this is this may be weird to have a
relationship with your contractor in
this way but he was talking about
Barbara he was like she is pure love
she's pure love like that's what Barbara
is Barbara is just like again you're not
gonna get more pure love out of another
dog so that is that that's a the risk is
I feel like a it's a guarantee that with
with your next dog you're not gonna you
won't get that much love right and so I
mean I'm just like okay well this is
such a good thing we got such a good
thing going I'm a willing to take
people's you know it feels we hide ways
glances at me it's not like she's gonna
wear a doggie shirt that says I'm a
clone not the original that would be
funny though I mean what about what
about cloning people yeah let's let's
clone our wives if they if they pass
untimely I mean I think that's why it's
so weird it's like you'd never do that
you never do that to a human it's
unnatural well there's a there's some
there's other reasons why we went in
cloner wise because they would be a baby
yeah well that's what I was trying to
tell you this is gonna be awkward for a
quite some time that's why I was trying
to tell you about Twilight that I didn't
get to was it that wolf guy he he made a
connection with the baby and then waited
for it to grow old and then they became
they hooked up that that's creepy with
the the the vampires girl its baby but
okay don't think of it in the context of
a relationship that's so much in that
Twilight I go back to it that's creep
that's creepy but let's just say there's
a okay there's a great
mind like a person who does incredible
things right I don't know
name someone who we consider to be
incredible that does incredible things
that Ryan's toy review okay exactly
somebody who has just impacted culture
for the better we're like well when Ryan
from Ryan's toy review dies what are we
gonna do we need we need and you can get
and when he's a baby it's like you don't
have to wait long for him to do his
thing again that's right I like within
three years basic instant gratification
almost from a clone force bear would be
the channel would be dark for just a
couple of years right and you for that
time you could just do videos that are
just like retrospective like this is
what you're gonna get don't forget
toddler toys they could have they could
start much earlier than my baby put him
as a just a newborn a newborn toys are
their channels where parents just get
their newborns to review products just
throw a rattle in the cage and let's see
what happens well there should be there
should be I mean I think you can exploit
your child from a very early age if you
want to did I answer your I don't think
you have to wait until they're five with
our Ryan's toy review thought experiment
did we reach the conclusion right well
first of all can human cloning be done
I don't think human cloning can be done
as effectively and reliably right or is
it just is it just unethical at this
point but could they could they really
do it and like they wouldn't be like
screwed up in some weird way like what
where is the science of cloning these
days there was the there was the
experiment I think it was in China a few
months back where they were doing
genetic mutations for medical purposes
but it wasn't creating a clone was using
CRISPR on people but nowhere gene edited
kids gene-editing kids and there wasn't
that's happening but there were there's
there's there's side effects there's
genetic side effects you you know you
you try to you try to get rid of this
one thing but then other things pop up
well okay
so what if they could create a clone for
you that didn't have a head of a dog
know of yourself okay they're like okay
we're growing this clone of you that
doesn't have a head and we're gonna
harvest the organs if as needed you need
a heart well we got your heart over here
that's cool in this baby and this baby
without a head
you're gonna get a baby heart you have
to wait for the baby to get old enough
the headless baby's got to grow up got a
review some I ever really finals I never
spent a lot of time thinking about the
the ethics of this but it does sound
like a can of worms that we probably
don't want to open we don't need more
people we've got too many we don't need
to clone them all worms are clones by
the way that is true isn't it are they a
sexual they all look to say worms are
not a sexual I'm sure some some worms
are just messing with you let's ask this
next question
Jennifer headhorn asks how do you know
when a new place you move to finally get
that feeling of home quoting quotes what
are the types of things you experience
that make it a home you both had to move
far from North Carolina which you have
many fond memories of but do you still
consider it your one true home or do you
get the same feelings about California
now as you did with North Carolina just
as a side note I find myself watching
our mythical roadtrip videos from Fuquay
to LA this is Rhett Link's America
and so it begins the mythical road trip
with rhett and Link
I can't remember exactly I think in
preparation for VidCon and a potential
bit about being on YouTube for over a
decade because that's how long vidcon's
been going on to ten years in the tenth
year I ended up going on a rabbit trail
of our own videos after looking at other
people's but I watched our if you don't
know our mythical road trips when we
moved out to LA we had fan meetups at
rest stops all across America and we
documented the whole thing and we made
all types of videos some on the Rhett
link channel some on what ultimately
became the good mythical morning channel
it was just our second vlog channel at
the time but we captured conversations
about our xpect
expectations of moving to LA and like
our hopes and fears were kind of
peppered in to the story of like meeting
mythical beasts and seeing parts of the
country having never driven across the
country mm-hmm it was a sweet time hmm
in our friendship Brett I'm glad we
documented dad yeah and some people
commented I'm glad I found this is
edited really well we didn't edit it
chris McCaleb did yeah shout out to him
but anyway it brought back memories of
that moment when we're yeah it was a big
deal to finally uproot both of our
families throw all of our possessions
actually we we threw all the possessions
that we needed for to move into a
furnished apartments so we shared a
u-haul and then we towed my minivan and
then you and I drove out and our
families flew out once we got to Los
Angeles but um I mean that was a huge
milestone and yeah as we did discuss in
a number of those videos just didn't
know you know we were coming out to make
commercial Kings for IFC not knowing if
it would last more than a season and it
didn't anyway
if you want to watch those you can
they're still out there quite nice but I
think that I know that I was probably
more than than in all four of the four
of us probably more than anyone else I
was of a mind that we're not going back
like I was like we're going out there I
don't care how this goes
we're staying you know I'm saying like
that my mentality was we're gonna go out
there and even if commercial Kings
doesn't work we're gonna we're gonna do
something we're gonna do we need to make
it happen out there I was just kind of
committed to it I think jesse was in a
different way committed to that
happening not a this is where your
career is gonna take off but more I'm
just ready for something new
ready for a change you know she had
grown up we lived in the house that was
across the street from the house that
she came home from the hospital in
really lie her parents house was across
the street from our house and she went
from living with her parents to being in
college for just a couple of years until
we got married and we were in Chapel
Hill but then quickly got back down a
few quays so I think that she was just
ready for a change that her personality
so but I think that there was a bit more
trepidation on the Neal side associated
with the unknowns of uprooting our
entire family moving him out there
I mean Landon lando was in a crib
yeah Shepard was - I was talking to him
about this other day I was like you
don't really like your whole life has
been in California
yeah Lando doesn't and even more so
Atlanta is a great year remember I may
be nothing I don't think Lando remember
anything because Shepard was 2 and he
doesn't remember anything
no all right very very like sketchy
stuff so the risk was lower then they
would go back we would go back like we
were out here for six months then we
went back for a few weeks before we came
back out again get the rest of our stuff
but I you know I would say that where it
stands now we moved in 2011's 2019 so we
just passed our eighth year we're in so
we're in our ninth
your being here and interestingly we're
going to where when you listen to this
well will be a I think we'll be about to
go back we're gonna go back to to Buies
Creek to create something that you'll
find out about later but Wells now you
will spend some time it'll be it's gonna
be related to the book bleak Creek
because you know bleak creeks based on
Buies Creek loosely tight more tightly
in some ways than others but we're gonna
go back not just to where we were we
last live but to our home at where we
grew up and whenever I get to North
Carolina especially when you go during
the summer and you're immediately hit
with this blanket of damp muggy air I
don't think I'll ever lose the sensation
that I am home that I'm like really
really like this is home this is yeah
this is where I grew up this is where I
this is where I became a man the roots
man you tap into the roots it's like
it's like getting back on a bicycle yes
you just kind of it just feels right
and I don't think they'll ever be a time
where I'm driving around Los Angeles or
hiking in one of these you know very
desert II landscapes around town when
you go into nature where I don't feel a
little bit like a visitor I don't and I
just don't think I'll ever get over that
because if you if you moved around a
bunch of different places growing up
which we didn't we were basically in
Buies Creek for our entire adolescence I
don't think you can lose that so in my
deepest core I definitely still consider
North Carolina home and I still feel
like a visitor here and I don't think
that I can overcome that but I have
different feelings just on a in a
general way I I can get into that after
we hear your perspective well I I agree
and 100% of relate to tapping back into
the to my roots when I go back home that
like like I just said it is going back
home
this is this is where I'm from this is
where my people still are you know
family old friends landmarks you know
you you you leave the airport you drive
back home
I got I got grandparents still living in
the same place they've always been in I
got mom you know in in the same county
that we always that that when we when I
grew up we're the same place you know so
it's like you travel those same roads
and you access all of those memories and
nothing's gonna ever take that away
nothing's gonna ever replace that but I
do consider in a different inflection of
the word home maybe a slightly different
definition but I do have a feeling that
Los Angeles is my home now it is
legitimately home for me and I think the
question is what how long it take for it
to get to that point I think a lot of it
has to do with you know my kids
absolutely consider this place home you
know this is the place where they've
built all of those memories and you know
Lincoln is hard pressed at you know at
14 to have a ton of memories back in
North Carolina Lando has none and so it
was Lily who had to make more of a
transition but I mean it was she was
still young enough that it wasn't that
big of a deal I mean she had a she had a
best friend that she's still in contact
with she has like a best north carolina
friend Lizzie who was in the pit my
stroller video yeah right she's like she
probably had the funniest voiceover well
there was it was you know who's the
sleigh there's so many funny voiceovers
but anyway I think our kids considering
this home goes a long way towards me
considering at home because we're like
we're making our lives here and every
day is more memories that you you know
you're putting your roots down
but I also think it has to do with
settling and physically to a house
mm-hmm that you know when we first moved
out that first six months we were living
in Los Feliz which is super cool in my
opinion
neighborhood you got these got these
hills where I think Katy Perry lives up
there and those in the hills and then
you go down to the to the shops and you
got the super trip hey let's go let's go
to Little Dom's
let's go Little Dom's and get us some
give us some Italian food we stayed in
it but we stayed in this furnished
apartment we knew we knew nothing about
where we should be no it was no was not
decorated and it was very cold the way
that it was decorated like super modern
yeah gray under lit like it way you know
it just wasn't how I wanted things to be
you like a bright well I would look it I
would go in the bathroom in the mirror
yeah antique burn bright environment I
couldn't see myself in the freaking
mirror yeah I had to buy a a mirror with
a with a I had to buy a vanity mirror
like one of those makeup mirrors in
order to be able to see my face in my
own bathroom
it just didn't you know me I really like
things to be how I like him to be so
that was really that wasn't home I mean
it was a furnished apartment then we go
back and get our stuff we come back out
we moved into a house we had a yard but
I didn't really know anybody in the
neighborhood and a couple of the
neighbors that we met it was kind of
like I feel like you don't like me there
was a weird vibe in the place we were
where we were yeah and we were it was
from a financial standpoint things are
tenuous for a number of years there as
we were moving into like pain painful
amount of rent at these place if you are
in the Greater Los Angeles area with a
family you better you better get it
together very quickly
yeah because you will be run out of town
just because it's so expensive to live
here yeah so there was there was
definitely if you're - there was like I
don't know if this is sustainable the
furnished apartment that we rented cost
over three times my mortgage back in few
uh in Fuquay it costs over it costs
seven times my mortgage I think you're
just bad at math dude no I I had bought
my house much later in my house was back
home was yeah actually I bought a I got
a really good deal on my on my house
but yeah the rent for an apartment that
was smaller than the house that I owned
but it was finished seven times my
mortgage yeah
that's painful and then we rent I mean I
think you know we were fortunate enough
to purchase homes and I think
psychologically yeah you're really
putting your roots down when you're like
saying I'm buying this place and yeah
it's that you're at now so I and I think
that you would with your personality
like getting getting everything the way
that you want it yeah is a big part of
your personality less less of mine so I
don't like when I thought about this
question I didn't think it all about
physical home physical homes and where
we're at and being in where we were
before and where we're at now it was
much more just the vibe that I get from
the city in like hey you know I'm saying
like a and I do remember a a very
specific point and it actually was
pretty early on
it definitely wasn't while we were in
Los Feliz it was after that and where I
had flown back home and we still say
flying home to North Carolina that's
what we say that's what we will probably
always say that regardless of how long
we're here but I remember arriving back
at LAX which is not the most it's not
the most welcoming Airport like when you
get to rtu your
like do people actually fly out of here
hey yeah it's it shut down because
there's not literally a crowd of people
that you have to work your way through
and a million people honking their horns
as soon as you get to where you're gonna
get picked up but anyway every time you
get to LAX regardless of what time of
day regardless of what day of the year
circus it's absolutely bonkers how much
traffic there is but I remember getting
back to LAX and walking out and waiting
for our a ride home and feeling like and
I wasn't I wasn't like trying to feel
this it just hit me I was like I'm home
this feels like home because can you but
can you link it to something I feel like
I am now returning to the the the
basically the the momentum has shifted
there's a there is a what do you call it
when you get enough tipping point
tipping point but you're like there's
enough momentum what is that word we're
looking for inertia yeah we're not
saying the word I don't know why I can't
remember at this point but basically
critical mass there's enough critical
mass in Los Angeles now and I think it
does have to do with like familiarity
and like comfort and so that does have
to do with like the physical home or
whatever but it just felt like the
critical mass of where I kind of
considered my home to be had moved had
come with me on the plane back to Los
Angeles and now I was stepping into this
environment that I felt like I knew
understood and could thrive in well I I
know what I'm saying I know a couple of
specific factors at least for me so try
these on for size I mean in general a
sense of community like actually having
friends people that like if something
goes wrong your impulse is to call
somebody who also lives in Los Angeles
to like get help or advice as opposed to
calling someone where you used to live
you know I think that's a telltale sign
can who do you call in need and then do
you have friends do are you making
connections
or your your kid in you know partner
doing the same thing I think also it's
like at the moment you feel hungry and
you're sitting on your couch and places
come to mind that you can just get in
there are knives angles yeah right you
start thinking of plays you know what
i'ma go and get it so and so i'ma gonna
I'm gonna get a sub from this place I'm
gonna get a I'm gonna get some
Mediterranean food from this place not
the eight other places you know cuz I've
tried them all I've got my favorites I
know where I'm gonna get the
cheeseburger and i'ma go to the pizza
place and when I go in there the guys
gonna know me by name I mean that's
really home right when the pizza guy
knows you I think another point is we
went to the pizza place they were
closing and he said alright and we're
like I'm sorry you're closing and then
he was like you know what place your
order I'll deliver it to your house and
he knew it cause he knows what houses
yeah that's a good sign yeah I'm home
baby
when when I can almost telepathically
order pizza I'm home and trust me I
think that's probably Christie's first
measure of home is do I know my pizza
guy I think being able to navigate six
years for her to being being able to
navigate the landscape and not need GPS
GPS I think is it know basically if you
live in any city you probably always
have your GPS on because you never know
when you're gonna run into like
variables traffic and accidents and
stuff like that but but you won't get
lost if your phone dies yeah cuz there
la is huge and I remember you know we
used to come out here before we before
we were doing commercial Kings we would
come out here cuz of course we did that
amazing hit show on the CW in 2007
called online nation so good it got
cancelled after four episodes but we
would come out to work on that and then
to come out and pitch other things we
were trying to
make things happen here and and we would
stay at the Beverly garland hotel on
vine
what is that on no.not Vineland Vineland
I just passed it the other other night
where you're on Ventura because we went
to eat with some piece of people in
Studio City we were on Ventura
took a left on Vineland and you know you
go past that little shopping center that
had the city walk that we like would
walk to the city walk down from the
Beverly garland yeah our world was the
bad block that block and then if we were
to drive it was we would take the 101
through the mountains down to somewhere
in Hollywood to do something to have a
meeting maybe go all the way to Beverly
Hills yeah that that was that was it and
that's just a very small sliver of Los
Angeles and then once you can kind of
like oh I can draw the mat for me I know
this is like Jesse couldn't do this
because she doesn't she i annoy her to
the point that I try to understand the
geography in my mind yeah but for me
that was a big point like because in
North Carolina like of course when we
were in the North Carolina lease up
until the end like there was we there
was no GPS like you didn't you just you
didn't use GPS to get anywhere so you
could get everywhere you needed to go by
just you just knew the environment and
you kind of always knew where you were
so when that happened to me in Los
Angeles it started to feel like home and
I'm not was that was a big moment you
know in britain's been living with us
for half a year
he's traveling a lot with the the
opportunities that he has for making
music but i mean our our home is this
home base but i I'm not I think it I
don't think I'm going on a limb here to
say that like he doesn't consider Los
Angeles home I mean after six months I
mean also living with you he's living in
my clothing a very small yeah area and
you know we asked him I'll ask him so
what you know where did you go today and
he's like I got lunch at jack-in-the-box
and then like the
next day I'm like what would you would
you go today's like I wa went back to
jackin about haha I was like Brittany
there's other places besides
jack-in-the-box you should shoot you
know you got to branch out so he started
to do that but he also pointed out
there's a lot of different menu items a
jacket about yeah yeah it's like seven
restaurants in one they got egg rolls it
- freaking jackin yeah they got tacos
it's crazy
jack is crazy he can't be boxed in
Jack is out of the box man he is out of
the box they knock out of the box missed
an opportunity there for the name but
you know it's it takes time and you
gotta meet people and you gotta just
can't eat it's a jack-in-the-box if
you're gonna make it if you're gonna
you're gonna make this house a home yeah
that girls aren't bad they're I'm a fan
but I'm like the only one in my family
that's a fan I don't need to be yeah I
don't need I don't need any fast food on
a regular basis so it's fine alright
let's move on so so we both think it we
both feel like it's home oh yeah and a
lot of people ask do you ever think
you're gonna go back to North Carolina
and there's no like default okay when
we've done our time here in Los Angeles
yes the default is that we're gonna go
back to North Carolina at this point
there
there is no there's nothing like that in
play it's like this is where we're at
this is where our lives have been
establishes we're like links that are
kids lives have been established so I
don't see that happening but yeah who
knows what'll happen I love North
Carolina
I love living here and I don't I miss
things about it but I don't miss living
there given the home that we made here
very happy I agree Russell alert oh
what's your favorite song to sing in the
shower
hmm favorite song to sing in the shower
I listen I don't sing in the shower
because I got I got too much on my
every single thing that I'm doing
perfectly which I've spoken about at
length oh yeah underperforming episode
of good mythical more if it hides expose
it if it flops lift it oh god I haven't
thought about that your routine is so
detailed that you don't have time for
singing in it listen if you watch that I
want it except the part about peeing on
your feet
it stops snorting into the microphone
turn Tay Zonday your nose away dude I
did a second ago but then that one was
just out of nowhere I just had to do it
right into the microphone yeah I don't
have a filter for that that's why it
sounded like keep going how to filter
key filter for that right haze on day
that thing okay turn away from the mic
to sniff Britain sautes on day and
jackin the-box
I'm lying he did see him somewhere he
came home and he told me he was like you
know that Chocolate Rain guy yeah he's
still he's still in LA calling it home
yeah what was I saying before you
snorted all over myself oh except for
the peeing on the feet part which I was
suggesting that you do in the shower
pretty much everything else that I
talked about in that episode I
legitimately do and every time I take a
shower there is a the majority of my
brain power is directed towards just
what what's the verb I'm looking for
doing I'll just say doing my system I
ain't got time to sit there and just
like here's the thing that ledger
fleecing Steiff thing that's the sad
fact I think that we have we have
pinpointed the weakness in your system
and I think that this is a metaphor in
or an allegory for many different areas
of life I don't want to I don't want to
have a deep introspection I don't want
to know if you're too committed to the
system if you're too committed to the
system you can't stop and enjoy other
things might be right so I'm not gonna
live cuz singing in the shower which I
definitely do because as everyone knows
the acoustics and make you sound a lot
better than you actually sound there's
just something I I've done it since I
was a kid now I will say that I have a
window in my shower and I look out
buta I got a beautiful view while I'm
naked in washing I'm looking out the
window and I'm I'm affirming myself and
I'm doing healthy things affirming
yourself yeah remember what you were
there
yeah I didn't listen to a lot of what
you said I was just kind of a prop for
that it was fair that was late in the
episode you'd glazed oh here's the thing
so so you sing in the shower now as well
as throughout your entire life you know
and say it's a I would say it's like a
thirty percent of the time that's that
seems like a lot to me for a grown-ass
man what's the last thing you sing in
the shower well the only thing I love
about this question from Russell is that
I have a song that I only sing in the
shower and I would not have been able to
tell you that until somebody asked me I
am shocked I would have bet I would have
bet the amount to clone a Barbra
Streisand dog that you would not sing in
the shower in the shower it just seems
so vulnerable like people can hear you
man like I don't know I've got missed
lots of misconceptions about me man I
think that you're perpetuating these
misconceptions no I'm a very vulnerable
person no I it's a it's a specific on
average I'm not saying that you're not
vulnerable I'm saying it's a specific I
don't know it's like we both have a
level of self-awareness that I think
would prevent I'm putting myself in this
boat yeah but I'm gonna shower in my own
home it's not being broadcast but like
if to the neighborhood if Chrissy's
walking in and out of the bathroom I
don't know something on a psychological
level I'd be like it's kind of
ridiculous that I'm singing sometimes I
will sing in the shower and Jessi will
join me from outside of the shower and
we will sing songs together what is this
a Disney movie see I'm just telling you
that's the way it goes down in the
McLoughlin bathroom you know what that's
beautiful Jesse and I sing songs in the
bathroom like try to harmonize with each
other it's not an uncommon thing it's
not like oh it's not like a half of the
time but it's not unusual
nursing all right let me I may be this a
turnover leaf for me cuz i'm cuz you
seem like the kind of person who would
want to sing in the shower but you've
gotten in your own way that's probably
true you need to let go what is your
song I don't even know if I'm gonna say
the right in the name of the song but
it's by Dobie gray what are you talking
about it's not give me the beat boys I
think it's so it's not that one you I
have sung that song in the shower but
that's not it it's the love and arm song
I don't sing it if you could see me now
the one who said that he'd rather wrong
the one who said he'd rather be alone if
you could only see me now oh I've been
too long in the wind and too long in the
rain taking any comfort that I can
looking back and longing for the freedom
of my chains from my chains and lying in
your loving arms again I do not know you
don't know this song know it you don't
know that doubly gray song it's one of
the best man ah it must smell so good in
the shower better in the shower well
I've got a cold he didn't sound bad but
I would hope it sounds better in the
shower again
huh now that's my shower song in in high
school I would sing at the top of our
lungs in the shower I've lost that part
of myself I need to get it back I would
sing Clint Black I think Clint black in
the shower because we were both going to
like a Clint black face yeah and singing
a lot of Clint black
lately I've been singing Diamond Rio in
the shower because I started listening
to Diamond Rio that's good I start pick
apart I start walking your way and you
start walking mine I would sing the sad
Clint Black songs maybe I took for
granny
you'd be around to pick me up on my way
down I can't sing that low in the shower
I could yeah you know just killing time
in the shower just killing time and I
would get out of the shower and my mom
we our house was so small you could be
anywhere in it you hear me in the shower
and my mom would say you sound good
you sounds so good I'm good in that
shower sounds so good I love it when you
sing in the shower and you've let go
with that man let go he left that back
in North Carolina you got to bring it to
California it makes it more home maybe I
need to move back no I think you can
just start singing in the shower
gimme the shower boys and seeing my soul
I want to do one more quick very quick
one I know you got it you had a wreck in
effect but tan brand asks what is the
correct answer - what's up this made me
laugh what's up because I thought about
our college roommate Greg because
typically you would say nothing well III
think normal responses to this are
nothing nothing much what's up you you
are or you usually what's up what's up
you can say what's up back to somebody
you can throw it right back at him all
those would be but literally every time
and Greg wasn't being funny when he did
it was funny but he wasn't trying to be
funny like right when we first started
we one of the first things we noticed
about Greg when we first met him yeah
yes you say what's up Greg and Greg says
good good he would say it like that
what's up Greg good good good anyway and
he had this leg here it's like it it was
like this carefree kind of pop to it
like his head would Bob in his bottom
lip would come up I mean he was good man
support the upper lip - in kind of a
smirk good yeah because he he was under
the impression that that was that he was
under the influence not uh not at that
time of joy man he was
under the impression that this is the
correct response to what's up and I
don't only ever talked about it I don't
I don't know 100% that he didn't do it
for a fact but he never we never
discussed it there were a lot of things
about Gregg that we didn't want to pull
back the curtain you know you just let
it be gray yeah it's like it's better to
just take it at face value yeah just
like whenever we talked about studying
and he'd say man you know what you know
you don't learn anything that sounds
like a sound reasoning foundation to not
do my homework and I think and I've got
felt what at me I've got many tweets
from people who say that they are
employing Gregg's philosophy like
they're like I know what you know I sat
down the study and then I just remember
what Gregg said I don't think that's
great advice if your goal is to make
good grades if your goal is just to
enjoy yourself while you're in school
and not really use the big degree that
you're getting then that's good advice
I'm not using my engineering degree so
it worked for me we did a rhett and Link
cast and we had Greg call in and we had
a discussion with Greg I don't know if
that one's been posted to the mythical
society I don't believe it has but I do
remember that happening hmm okay that's
all the questions weed Greg with three
G's nice man
took some time on those questions we'll
get to more questions next time we do an
episode like this baby Rick baby one two
three four baby erect baby one two I
forgot I had to give a wreck so I'm like
scrambling racking my brain I was coming
home I was gonna leave for work
yesterday and Christy sent me a text she
was like you know we got this we got a
teenager party happening over here Lilly
had a bunch of her friends over and you
know we're trying to be that house where
the friends come over and hang out
because we think that it that way we can
we can
be in the mix you know we can kind of
note we can have our pulse on what's
happening in the friend group but like
you can have your finger on the pulse I
don't think you get to have the pulse
right right
yeah yeah we're not Christy tells me to
keep my distance not to try to bop and
get in there and be cool dad stay on the
fringe right or be the guy who picks up
stuff that they need and they wanted to
roast marshmallows on our fire pit I was
like you know and we've been meaning to
get these and so I went to the REI and
I'm recommending that you go to the REI
and get they got these fancy skewers I
love it when someone has thought about
everything associated with something
that you know you could just get a a
dumb metal version to poke your eye out
with it's like fully retractable it's
like a pointer it retracts in and out
well how much is this 13 dollars a piece
there you get two of them well how many
did you buy for this group of twenty
kids over at your house well you know me
well you probably got four of them I got
two packs which is four total and I told
Lily I was there doing four at a time
and you sit around watching each other
where's the party man that's part of it
you wish you had gotten enough skewers
for people to pack into your fire pit
which I think twelve people could be
hired but I told Lily [ __ ] I was like I
think you when I brought him home I was
I think you should I was like bragging
about it look what I got there
retractable they got to fork on the end
and look you can hold the handle and
rotate your thumb and it will twist the
entire thing for perfect marshmallow
roasting but with these four that I've
got I would recommend that you choose
you didn't even get enough for your own
family dancing you didn't even get
enough for the needles they're expensive
man I love you $12 this is a what are
you gonna do in your family's roasting
marshmallows there's gonna be one person
out I'm a everybody doesn't need to
roast someone's on like graham cracker
duty
somebody's on chocolate Duty somebody's
an assembler and some and some people
are Roasters I'll make everybody do all
there's more some people are better
roasted
than others and if you give everybody
roasters eyes are gonna be poked out all
marshmallows are gonna be burnt one
person going through the emergency room
is part of your first camping trip and
it's just it's a rite of passage I found
an awesome thing and I ain't buying too
many so you're you recommended this but
enough for pretty as experiment I just
I'll add a wreck to the wreck I think
you should get one per family member
then if I had to do their two in a pack
so I would have have one extra that's
wasteful give it a Jane for its backup
for when one breaks they sound like they
got a lot of moving parts I'm the
designated roaster well they know you
need one two hands two backups so the is
this an official REI brand thing or you
just can get it at REI you just get it
at REI
you can't get it at the grocery store
which is where I was gonna go until
Jenna told me to go to Ralph's this is
Jenna's wreck Ralph are you yeah I was
gonna go to Ralph's but you got she
recommended you did you get the
marshmallows or else or did you get
marshmallows at REI as well I didn't get
marshmallows they already had them
you're welcome there you go home is
where the heart is in your home in your
ears is with us hashtag ear biscuits let
us know what makes a home home to you
homey and we'll be right back here again
next week to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right to
watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]